l'église saint-joseph totalement rénové
vous souvenez certainement de je vois
montréal l'an dernier avait été lancée
par un ancien banquier jacques ménard
pour relancer la métropole est bien le
jeu voit montréal est devenue je fais
montréal et vincent maisonneuve on a
voulu faire un bilan un an plus tard
aujourd'hui et on a montré cet
exemple-là de l'église saint-joseph tout
à fait exactement vous savez on échange
et non pour monter qu'on était
maintenant en mode réalisation de ces
181 projets qui avaient été proposées
l'année dernière à pareille date
à ce jour un an plus tard il ya 55
projets qui ont été réalisés un très bon
exemple c'est celui de la transformation
de l'église saint joseph s'est situé
dans le sud ouest dans l'arrondissement
du sud-ouest se néglige qui était
abandonné depuis huit ans bien promoteur
qui a eu l'idée de transformer sans une
salle pour tenir des événements mais
également un incubateur d'entreprises ou
sous sol un projet qui n'avançait pas le
promoteur avait beau essayé essayé ça
n'avançait pas or grâce à cette
initiative je vois montréal maintenant
je fais montréal
tout a débloqué vous invite à écouter
les propos de la femme qui est derrière
ce projet de transformation de lait
suivi d'un extrait de jacques ménard
l'esti gâteurs de toute cette initiative
partie du projet de jeu vous à montréal
au début c'est là que la boule a
vraiment commencé à rouler beaucoup plus
vite
c'est clair que la mobilisation de la
communauté au sens large
ces ligres et dian de barrage pour
soutenir la relance des vignes les
villes prennent un jour un de ces
cassettes un hachoir saisir d'après
d'après nos études nous c'était juste un
coup et là on a encore un bon bout de
chemin à faire
au delà du 375e moi j'ai bien conscience
qu'on a les ingrédients pour le faire
donc vincent on comprend que ça va se
poursuivre l'initiative tout à fait
monsieur ménard est convaincu que d'ici
le printemps 2016 on va voir au moins
une centaine de projets de réaliser
l'ensemble des 181 projets réalisés à
temps pour 2017 pour le 375e
mais il espère que cette initiative loeb
ça va se poursuivre dans le temps
toujours pour des projets porteurs pour
relancer la métropole
c'est l'air magnifique cette
restauration en tout cas là les images
tout à fait loi merci vincent au revoir